are you wondering why I'm holding a
penguin well you know what day it is
how did I do that
that's not magical editing check this
out papa papa come on look at this you
go half blah we think I'm a magician
come on this is so much fun how about we
just leave the Hat on him I like that
hat but I kind of like the stomach too
wow it looks even cooler on camera in
all seriousness Merry Christmas Happy
Holidays no matter what holiday you
celebrate I know we accomplished some
pretty amazing things together picked up
like two and a half million subscribers
together we've educated the world 200
million views this year but I want to do
it even bigger for 2020 so I sat down
and wrote 10 epic goals that are
actually smart goals specific measurable
attainable realistic and have a time
component you ready
for the third consecutive year I do not
want to miss a single YouTube posting
date I mean it's really hard to post on
Wednesdays and Sundays without missing a
single video we've been doing it since
April 2017 dan and I and I want to
continue that into 2020 I want to make
sure that even if I take a vacation or I
get busy I have videos pre-filmed so you
always have quality fun educational
videos to watch and check out that's on
me so if I fail you know where to yell
at me goal number two I want to finally
complete
Behr's Hospital training certification
it's taken forever I had to wait until
he turned 2 now I just got him neutered
he's ready to go he's prime I'm starting
to take him where there's crowds there's
noise so he gets used to it and the more
exposure I can get him the more
comfortable he's gonna be when he
actually spends time with me at the
hospital not only do I want to have bear
with me when I see patients but
afterwards I'm gonna volunteer some time
and take them into the supporting paws
program that we have in my hospital and
visit the pediatric ward or even the
adult ward where patients are staying
for an extended period of time
bear cheers me up and I know that if
someone's sick in the hospital where
they can get lonely pretty easily it's
nice to see a fluffy friendly face just
like bear oh by the way look how pretty
he is he just
he's looking so spiffy where you looking
awesome look at him I don't know if you
can tell but he's super welcoming he
smells like the downy bear or whatever
the Cottonelle god I'm messing that up
give me five four goals for the new year
whoa that was a good high-five what is
this very gross goal number three I want
to read at least 24 books next year I
guess that technically means I could
listen to 24 books next year because you
know I love audible I want to read two
books a month I normally do one I want
to step it up I want to go into
overdrive I want to expand my mind
because I feel like when I read more
books I can better transfer you more
knowledge better knowledge more
interesting facts and quotes and things
like that so I'm really gonna make it a
mission to step outside my comfort zone
read more listen more and be an
all-around knowledge sponge goal number
four I want to connect more with you
I've tried to answer as many questions
as I can in the comments and am i
responding to comments videos even on my
reddit page but I want to step it up and
really form a community around
everything that we're doing I think you
and I have the same mission learn as
much as we can about ourselves about the
mind the body health medicine but do it
in a responsible way where it's fun but
we're still putting evidence-based facts
first the way we're gonna do this is I'm
gonna give you my number literally this
is my number nine one seven three three
six four nine oh six nine one seven
three three six four nine oh six now a
lot of people when I put this on
Instagram freaked out and like oh my god
I can't believe Mike's kidneys number
must be fake it is absolutely not fake
here's my messages that are all coming
in when you text you're gonna get an
automated message for me that's not me
but then everything after that is gonna
be me now yes sometimes I send out a
mass text which is fine sometimes I'll
text you individually sometimes I wish
you a happy birthday on your birthday
with a dedicated video I think that's
pretty cool there's a lot of great
features in this app and if I want to
notify you about merch or a new cool
video concept or pull you on a specific
question this is a great way to do it I
promise I won't be texting you like
crazy and sometimes I just get bored I
just start answering questions or just
with people so definitely text me nine
one seven three three six four nine oh
six you have my number it's your move
goal numero Cinco I want to bring in new
faces to the YouTube channel
specifically because the goals got to be
specific ten new faces this year
youtubers celebrities even interesting
people with interesting stories like I
did before with Pam or dr. Espina I
actually have a few collabs lined up
early in the year with industry leading
doctors the top of their fields to not
only educate you but to educate me in
fact I just had an awesome collab with
wampa who is absolutely wild and
hilarious he's about to throw me out of
a plane if you don't know what I'm
talking about the links down below in my
description goal number six I want to
give away at least at least $50,000 in
2020 whether that means to charity or
through giveaways whatever and maybe we
could even hit the hundred thousand mark
before I tell you goal number seven
please don't judge me
Coll number seven is to launch my merch
line oh my god has this been a heartache
and a headache first I went ahead and
created all the designs for the
merchandise elf and I was so excited
about it this is like early summer I get
a company i partner with them they
approve my samples they send me samples
one sample comes in broken second sample
comes in flawed third sample has an
issue I can't have that god forbid they
start sending you the merch and you're
gonna be upset with me and you should be
and that all started happening towards
the end of November in December now I
feel rushed to put out poopy designs I
rather give you the most epic amazing
designs because 2020 is gonna be an epic
year so be prepared for some awesome
merch I mean like really awesome merch
Gold number eight is to do something I
should have been doing a long long time
ago I want to play tourist in New York
City my hometown where I've lived 20
plus years and visit five famous
landmarks I'm pretty embarrassed to say
that I've lived here for so long never
visited the World Trade Center
now the Freedom Tower the Empire State
Building there's so many cool places in
York City I haven't seen I'm making a
mission that I'm gonna see five places
by the end of 2020 and I want to vlog it
gold
nine meatless Mondays in 2019 I went
vegan I just finished up whole xxx video
coming soon and I realized I've been
eating a lot of meat so I'm trying to
cut back a little bit not only for
animals sake but also for the
environment there's a huge benefit to
cutting out meat at least one day of the
week it's a good start so I'm gonna make
the pledge for 2020 I will not eat meat
on Mondays goal number 10 my final goal
is to continue battling misinformation
but on the TV front I want to make at
least 60 TV appearances in 2020 this
year I did like 4050 but I want to take
it a step up and do more I'm so sick and
tired of news organizations getting the
medical stories wrong either getting us
over hype for some preliminary research
or telling us about some miracle
supplements or some miraculous diet
rents they don't exist it doesn't exist
my job is to go out there on the news
and give you the true stories about
what's going on what's actually
important for your health the same thing
that we do on this youtube channel and
maybe if we get our own show that can be
quite fun too let's see what 20/20 has
in store for us I want to challenge you
at home what are some things you want to
accomplish for 2020 again they have to
be a smart goal specific measurable
attainable realistic and have a time
component drop them down below in the
comments in addition in addition to what
you think I should do to celebrate my
milestone of hitting 5 million
subscribers come on guys that's crazy a
doctor having 5 million subscribers
that's only possible because of you and
I have to give you a huge thank you
without all of you watching at home this
channels nothing I'm nothing so thank
you for taking a stand for responsible
accurate medical information where we
could all laugh and have a good time
prove that doctors are human too and
really change the way we talk about
medicine and health it's because of you
this channels so awesome check out this
playlist of my favorite videos from 2019
all for you
make sure when you're watching them you
stay happy and healthy
[Music]